how are you feeling going from uh week
one into week two sort of what are the
emotions that uh you were having
i
well first of all i'm having so much fun
but i thought it would be
honestly a lot less nervous coming into
week two like being like oh i got week
one under my belt now i can chill
that was not the case at all for me and
dress for her so i was literally so
scared
and um
hopefully as time goes on i'll like
somehow learn how to control my nerves a
little bit but most of all i'm having a
ton of fun i love to dance
obsessed with my partner so
yeah i'm having a great time
that's awesome um i have to say uh
congrats on making it past the first
elimination and i feel like you get a
pretty good prize which is britney week
i mean can you tease what's coming
because i'm personally so excited five
six seven eight
[Music]
you guys are the first people to sing to
me and i love it so
down
no i'm pumped brittany's an icon it's
gonna be great um so obviously we talked
about cheryl uh what were the reactions
that you guys had when you found out
scared
yeah
yeah because
you know this is a lot of
all of that is very new territory for
the show even in its 30th season you
know we're celebrating 30th season in a
very unprecedented time
under
a lot of restraint you know so the fact
that we are on tv making live television
it takes a lot of personnel behind
any of this
that don't get enough credit that really
do a great job so
at that moment we on the back end we're
all you
who has communicated with them
who has crossed paths with them and you
know
as tedious as it is all the kobe
protocols that we have in place
that people don't love
uh they pay off in those moments because
we we had some certainty that okay we
but we did everything correctly so
um as far as them i'm glad that they
made it past
elimination and
you know he's a great talent and it's
just wonderful time on the show so it's
great to see them move on
i think i could speak for everybody when
i say that i'm very excited that cody's
made it to brittany week that's all i
had to say and he's gonna kill it
so pumped um olivia you know i think the
thing that's so great about the show is
it really gets to show people
you know in a new light it gets to show
people sort of you know everybody has
preconceived notions about everybody
what do you want people to learn about
you through this journey
um honestly i just feel like
i feel like a lot of people don't know
me that well and obviously that's
something i i want to you know be
vulnerable with and have people see a
different side of me but also i think
naturally i am like a closed off person
and so
uh hopefully people just see you know
more behind the scenes i feel like once
i get in front of a camera and it's like
a straight up interview i'm still like a
little bit like robotic and you know
trying to figure it out but
hopefully in like the natural takes of
just my actual personality and like you
know just vibing out with bow that
people see i have a strong work ethic
and that
i'm really excited and grateful to be
here and
hopefully i can learn how to dance even
more and that's kind of the goals so
that's what i love i think it's a matter
of comfort and trust
yeah i think in front of the lens for
her
answering questions
feeling
confident that it's going to be
presented in a way that is honest to her
will allow her to open up more but in
terms of proving her work ethic i think
she'll do that every week just by
dancing better you know let your actions
kind of speak for themselves so as
america gets to know the real olivia
we're going to earn their attention by
dancing well you know and that's
something we do have control over so we
just got to work hard
well i'll say lynn uh said it this week
he said you know the key to the show is
dancing better this week than you did
last week and you guys definitely did
that um how did you sort of feel after
this dance it was so beautifully done
how did you feel
really sometimes olivia forgets that
she's on live television like though
what'd you say
yes so sometimes no i just
oh i just sometimes curse accidentally
but
it's not like anything that bad i know
but the sentiment was
word
french
it's over
[Laughter]
yeah because it's not that i want it to
be over like let me make it clear i'm
having the time of my life and that's
why i'm just relieved every time like
that 55 seconds or 60 seconds or
whatever it is it's just like
we did it it's like really skydiving
anybody that has jumped out of a plane
before this is what this is like and
you're just because you're on your feet
it really feels like
you can't yeah i mean your feet
sometimes that's how nervous you are
and so that's what they go through and
inadvertently
i'm then parachute instructor that has a
really nervous human in front of me
dangling
i try and really keep it together for
him too but i think i do sometimes like
a bad job because i can't help myself
and i'm like so not great at disguising
my emotion i think like you can tell
immediately when i'm like tweaked or
anything so translation for uh
uh nervous nervous
you